you are about to enjoy a free preview
from marvel studios doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness this movie is
now available
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
ah
[Applause]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
do i know you
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
yes yeah
[Music]
oh
you're welcome
you know essential custom to bow in the
presence of the sorcerer's supreme yes
i'm aware of the customs
[Music]
that's incredible
yeah
[Music]
god
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
who's this yeah i was gonna ask the same
question hey kid
what did that creature want with you
where are your parents take her back to
the site
i'm not gonna kill you kid
i just bust my ass trying to save your
life remember
giant monsters i can clearly handle but
what bothers me is that last night you
were in my dream
that wasn't a dream
it was another universe
how much experience do you guys have
with multiverse we have experience of
the multiverse most recently there was
an incident with
what man spider-man he has the powers of
a spider hence the name gross
does he look like a spider no no more
like a man climbs wool shoots wet yeah
bingo out of his butt no oh well maybe i
don't know
honestly i hope not super weird
you're gonna get a stomach ache i'm from
another universe i know my stomach works
the same as yours i don't
i don't even know if you're from another
universe which is why i'm still sitting
here waiting for you to enlighten us
look i left a very nice wedding to save
a smart-ass kid from getting eaten by an
octopus who's one tell me christine's
you win holy [ __ ] you married christine
do you mind yes i do no i didn't yes
you need to explain to me what's going
on why was that octopus trying to eat
you
the thing was trying to kidnap me
it's like a henchman who works for a
demon
all we knew is that they wanted to take
my power for themselves what power
i can travel the multiverse
what
see what happens next order the entire
movie marvel studios doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness
you